[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris haynes senior nba
insider yahoo sports tnt sideline
reporter
host of posted up with chris haynes
podcast he was uh
one of the stars that emerged from the
bubble last year we always appreciated
his time
and uh his information that he gave us
while he was in the bubble he's
currently in las vegas then heading to
phoenix later today
game five coming up on saturday night
chris thanks for joining us
uh we just got word that kevin love is
uh withdrawing from the olympic team so
we have bradley beal and kevin love not
playing
who are going to be the replacements
well they have a
they have a ample amount of players that
they can pick from from the pool
um i know a player that has been
um campaigning behind the scenes of
trying to get on this team and that's
trey young of the atlanta hawks
uh you know we heard her talk of duncan
robinson with the miami heat the
sharpshooter as well
so uh colangelo has some he has some
tough decisions to make but uh
there's there's still a bunch of players
that i've talked to
um behind the scenes about up the
upwards of 10
that would like the opportunity to have
one of those two spots so uh
they'll they'll have a good they'll have
a good amount of options
why was kevin love on the team to begin
with
that is a good question bp um
experience i'm just going to go with
experience you know
i'll go with that that's the best i got
dp i got a lot of experience
come on i this is where i would have
hoped julius randle
zion williamson where you could you
could have younger players get that
opportunity to play
in olympic competition i mean that's
what i was hoping for and
i don't know what's going on behind the
scenes but i was like i was really
surprised that
kevin love was given an invitation so
well dp as far as
zion williamson goes it it's hard for me
to believe
that team usa did not ask him to play in
that
like that that's just like the you know
that's just like the
the gold golden standard of having a
young promising player
on on the roster he didn't even get an
invitation
to to try out no zion zion
zion i think believes i had an
opportunity i had an opportunity
okay uh which leads me to believe he
probably declined
oh okay the uh jason kidd
hire in dallas what does that mean for
luka doncic
well just somebody who's played the game
at that position at a high level
um somebody who i think with the
mavericks are hoping that jason kidd can
even accelerate
uh lucas learning curve in his nba and
and that's funny to say that you know
saying that you know that he's an
all-nba player right now but
jason kia just just his pedigree his
knowledge of the game
and they believe that jason kidd has
become a much better coach
over the last two or three years get
earning the championship of the lakers i
talked to rob polinka
over there with the lakers and he said
the things that they were able to do
some of the innovative sets that they
were putting out there on the floor
he credited jason kidd and so he got a
lot of praise over there lebron james
also praised kid so i think they feel
like
um kid can take this team to the next
level now i want to say this
dp is that it was somewhat
in the plans a few years ago but jason
kid to join the coaching staff
of rick carlin something happened
i don't know if that would i don't know
if carlisle didn't want him on this on
on the staff but something had happened
and
to cause that thing to fizzle out and so
that never
transpired and so now what ultimately is
happening is the dallas mavericks are
coming back full circle and getting a
guy that they want a part of the
organization
to begin with yeah but it didn't it
didn't make sense that rick carlisle
decides to leave a couple years left
on his contract he says hey you know
luca's going to win
multiple championships here did it come
down to luca didn't want rick carlisle
as his head coach
and mark cuban had to make that decision
to get rid of him
well i'll say this it you know it was a
poorly
uh it was a poorly um announced secret
that um luca didn't really get along
with rick carla
you know so that that was that was in
within league circle we've heard about
that you know
throughout throughout his tenure you
know rick carlisle is a coach who
uh wants a lot of control and i think
he's given
control to luca because he's just such a
great
phenomenal player but you know he's used
to you know
controlling the offense controlling
defense calling sets
and uh he had to allow luca to have
more reign being at the player that he
blossomed into but those two guys
just never it was never just pure
bliss with those two guys if you know
what i mean so
i i don't i don't have any um
information to say that luca
you know needed carlisle to be out to
stay there but
it wasn't a secret that they you know
that they made this decision i'm trying
to figure out what's going on in
portland with damian lillard
and and i i put myself in his position
you know you're 30 years of age you're
an unbelievable talent
but you're nowhere near an nba
championship
um and he looks around and he's got a
roster
that's full of injuries you you know are
you going to win with
cj mccollum as your running mate uh what
what is your place in history like you
start to think these things when you get
to
age 30. you got a good relationship
with dame um can he
can he get his wish and and uh and stay
in portland or can he get his wish
and leave portland what do you think is
more likely to happen
that's a good question d pete i
appreciate that tea up because i i have
a um
i have a story uh with damian lillard
dropping this morning
um any minute so um i was able to talk
with him and
here in vegas to just
get just try to find out what's going on
in his mind as it pertains to his tenure
with the portland trailblazers because
as of right now like this is the most
frustrating east beer you know i've said
that
since the season ended since they were
it was kind of like an upset with denver
because they didn't have two of their
best players
and denver still beat portland and so
dame
and i say this and i said this to
members of the portland trailblazers
organization as well
is that damon's always told me
he wants to compete for a championship
he wants to play for a title
and portland has always been a team that
they're going to be good
they're going to make the playoffs but
we all know how the story goes at the
end they always fizzle out
and if dame is telling me he wants to
compete for a championship
i have to hold the team to that standard
as well
even if the team's objective is not
to compete for a championship okay so
this article that's dropping
today on yahoo sports does damian
lillard
say that he wants to be traded no he
does he doesn't say that
we're we're not we're not even to that
point
you know it's not it's not even to that
point you know there are some
conversations that need to be had for it
for a decision like that to even be made
but uh as of right now you know he he
just wants to see
a change and uh he wants to get away
from the norm so
that is his focus yeah i just wonder
i i i mean let's just apply logic to
this
they're not winning anything anytime
soon
right right well
he'll if if that's the case if if if the
roster
is not conducive to being able to play
amongst the elites
then he has a decision to make
is there a possibility is ben simmons
involved in
in you know this equation of
that maybe dame could end up in
philadelphia i mean i don't like to do
talk radio throw out crazy trade
proposals but
ben simmons is available the question is
who wants him
what do you do with him and what do you
have to give up to get him
could you see ben simmons in portland
see ben simmons in portland and dame in
philly or just ben simmons in portland
or ben
simmons in portland and cj mccollum in
philadelphia like do you see a scenario
where portland is interested in ben
simmons
yeah i would think yeah i would think
there's some interest in ben simmons on
portland side
but i'm not sure at the cost of cj
and if portland is throwing in cj
i think it's going to take a little bit
more to get ben simmons
so with that being said i don't see
the philly portland as of right now i
don't see the philly
portland thing transpire where do you
see ben simmons going
that's a good question you look at look
at the teams that are being rumored you
talk about minnesota sacramento these
aren't
good teams you know these these are
teams that are
you know that are young and they're
still trying to develop players
you don't hear a lot of top-notch teams
you know clamoring to get ben simmons
right now but i think he's got to go to
a place where he can sort of
not hide but he needs to go where
there's a little less pressure on every
game every moment
every shot every free throw and like you
know i
i said orlando like let him go and let
him run a team
because we've seen when embiid is not in
there he's a different player
and i just wonder if he got away and got
into a situation
minnesota is not right for him
sacramento is not going to be right for
him
but i would think one of these other
teams where he could just sort of
houston like he could sort of run the
team a little bit that that's what i'd
be curious about
well those teams like i still put
minnesota sacramento into those teams
that you mentioned db
dp because there won't be the hot
there won't be the spotlight on him yeah
in those in those areas we're talking
about
philly man that's one of the biggest
markets where the fan
base is just so intense and if you're
playing bad poorly they're going to let
you know
and they're going to let you know like
nobody else has ever let you know so
he needs to get into an environment
where he can have mistakes and
he still needs to develop as great as he
is
i believe he's a two-time all-star one
of the best defensive players we have in
this league
but he has a lot of development to go
and i think
he's going to reach his full potential
right now
if he's on one of those lower market
teams which
won't have a lot of spotlight on him
where he can make mistakes and still try
to prosper
what do you think the media is going to
do react to chris paul if the suns don't
win this nba championship
i mean it's going to be it's going to be
tough
man um you know we we've seen chris paul
play at a high level fizzle out towards
the end
his best run before this point was in
houston we got to the the conference
finals
uh he was a hamstring away from
advancing and now they're up 2-0
this would just amplify all the talk of
people saying that chris paul
can't get it done in the clutch times in
clutch moments now there's still a lot
of time left for him to rectify that but
it's going to be a bad look if the sons
aren't able to get this done
it's always great to catch up with you
chris safe travels
have a great weekend and uh once again
thank you ep anytime bro take care
that's uh chris haynes a senior nba
insider for yahoo sports and has an
article with dame lillard coming out
this morning
and uh he also has the chris haynes
podcast host of posted up
with uh chris haines